Hello world.
It's a Raj.
In this video we're going to use genetic
programming to identify if some energy
is gamma radiation or not.
I'm getting angry gamma rays.
No, I wish data science is a
way of thinking about discovery.
A data scientist need to decide the
right question to ask like who's the best
candidate to vote for in the U s election?
Then decide what data set to use like
tweet history of candidates and pass
endorsements of each candidate and lastly,
decide what machine learning model to
use on the data to discover the right
answer live goes on with the right data
computing power and machine learning
model.
You can discover a solution to any problem
but knowing which model to use can be
challenging. For new data scientists.
There are so many of them.
That's where genetic programming can help.
Genetic Algorithms are inspired by the
Darwinian process of natural selection
and their use of generate solutions
to optimization and search problems.
They have three properties,
selection, crossover and mutation.
You have a population of possible
solutions to a given problem and a fitness
function.
Every iteration.
We evaluate how fit each solution
is with our fitness function.
Then we select the fitness
ones and perform crossover
to create a new population.
We take those children and mutate them
with some random modification and repeat
the process until we get the fittest
or best solution. So take this problem.
For instance, let's say you want to take
a road trip across a bunch of cities.
What's the shortest possible path you
could take to hit up each city once and
then return back to your home city?
This is popularly called the traveling
salesman problem in computer science and
we can use a genetic
algorithm to help us solve it.
Let's look at some high level python code.
We have the number of generations set to
5,000 and the population size except to
a hundred so we start by initializing
our population using our size parameter.
Each individual in our population
represents a different solution path.
Then for each generation,
we compute the fitness of each solution
and story in our population fitness
array.
Now we'll perform selection by only
taking the top 10% of the population,
which are our shortest road trips and
produce offspring from them by performing
crossover. Then you take those offspring
randomly and repeat the process.
As you can see in the animation,
eventually we will get an optimal solution
using this process unlike apple maps.
All right, so how does this all
fit into data science? Well,
it turns out that choosing the right
machine learning model and all the best
hyper parameters for that model
is itself an optimization problem.
We're going to use a python library
called teapot built on top of psycho learn
that uses genetic programming to
optimize our machine learning pipeline.
So after formatting our data properly,
we need to know what features to input
to our model and how we should construct
those features.
Once we have those features,
will input them into our model to train
on and will want to tune our hyper
parameters or tuning knobs
to get the optimal results.
Instead of doing this all
ourselves through trial and error.
Teapot automates the steps for us which
genetic programming and it will output
the optimal code for us plates
done so we can use it later.
So we're going to create a classifier
for gamma radiation using teapot after
installing our dependencies
and then analyze the results.
Teapot is built on the popular psyche
learn machine learning library,
so we'll want to make sure that
we have that installed first.
Then we'll install Penn does to help us
analyze our data and num Pi to perform
math calculations. Our first step
is to load our Dataset we use.
Penn does read CSV method
and set the parameter to the
name of our safe CSV file.
This is data collected from a scientific
instrument called a Charin [inaudible]
telescope that measures radiation in
the atmosphere and these are a bunch of
features of whatever type of
radiation it picks up. Thanks Putin.
Since the class object
is already organized,
we'll shuffle our data
to get a better result.
The eye lock function of the telescope
variable is pandas way of getting the
positions in the index and will
generate a sequence of random indices.
The size of our data using the
permutation function of num Pi's,
random submodule. Since all the
instances are now randomly rearranged,
we'll just reset all the
indices so they are ordered.
Even though the data is now shuffled using
the reset index method of pandas with
the drop parameter set to true will now
let our Televerde will know what our two
classes are by mapping both of them
to an integer with the map method.
So g or gamma is at the zero and
h or Hadrian is that the one?
Let's store those class labels,
which we're going to predict in a separate
variable called teleclass and use the
values attribute to retrieve them.
Before we train our model,
we need to split our data into
training and validation sets.
We'll use the train test split method
of psychic learn that we imported to
create the indices for
both. The parameters will
be the size of our dataset.
We want both sets to be a raise.
So we'll set the stratified parameter
to our array type and we'll define what
percent of our data we want
to be training and testing.
With these last two parameters.
We have a 75 25 split now in our data
and we're ready to train our model.
We'll initialize the teapot variable
using the teapot class with a number of
generations set to five on a standard
laptop with four gigs of Ram.
It takes five minutes per generation to
run, so this will take about 25 minutes.
This is so teapots genetic algorithm
knows how many iterations to run for and
we'll set verbosity to two,
which just means show up progress scarred
in terminal during the optimization
process. Then we can call our
fit method on our training data,
let it perform optimization
using genetic programming.
The first parameter is
the training feature set,
which were retrieved from our tele
variable along the first access for every
training index. The secondary
level is our training class set,
which will retreat from our
Televerde bubble like so.
We can compute the testing error for
validation using teapot score method with
validation feature set as the first
parameter and the validation class set as
the second we'll export the computed
python code to the pipeline.py class using
this method and name it in the perimeter
as a string. Let's demo this thing.
After training we'll see that after five
generations she pot chose the gradient
boosting classifier as the most
accurate machine learning model to use.
It also shows the optimal hyper parameters
like the learning rate and number of
estimators for us boy,
so to break it down with the right amount
of Beta computing power and machine
learning model, you can discover
a solution to any problem.
Genetic Algorithms replicate
evolution via selection,
crossover and mutation to find an optimal
solution to a problem and teapot is a
python library that uses
genetic programming to help
you find the best model and
hyper parameters for your use case.
The winner of the coding challenge
from the last video is Peter Amatrano.
He added some great deep dream samples
to is repository and even deep dream.
My own video, bad ass of the week,
and the runner up is Kyle Jordan.
Good job stitching all the deep dreams
frames together with one line of code.
The challenge for this video is to use
teapot and a climate change dataset that
are provide to predict the
answer to a question you decide.
This will be great practice and learning
to think like a data scientist posts.
You're getting humbling in the comments
and I'll announce the winner next time
for now. I've got to stay fit to
reproduce, so thanks for watching.